the house of the dragon will stand as
one for a further generation
who will it be
the brother
they name me king of the narrow sea
the daughter
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about the new promo trailer for house of
the dragon's fourth episode king of the
narrow sea this one is actually pretty
exciting because even as someone who's
read the book there are some questions
as to how some of the events they show
here play out this is because the book
fire in blood is written from the
perspective of several unreliable
narrators each of which has their own
spin on events ranging from towing the
targaryen family line to paint things in
the best possible light the downright
salacious in the case of mushroom just
to let you know before we dive in i will
be referring to the books but i won't be
revealing any future spoilers from them
and with that out of the way let's get
into it
the trailer opens with a shot that
appeared in the weeks ahead trailer that
came out after episode 1. it's an
overhead shot of the staff members
carrying lanterns and it appears they're
looking for someone we hear renera
reading the prophecy from aegon's dream
that her father told her about in the
first episode she's holding the cat's
paw dagger and you see that when it's
heated up there are symbols that are
revealed on the blade i don't know much
about written high valerian but the
implication here is that she's reading
the prophecy and you hear her say from
my blood come the prince that was
promised and his will be the song of ice
and fire it's interesting to think that
there was a message hidden there as this
was passed down through the generations
and that arya was carrying it around
none the wiser this is an excerpt from a
prophecy that daenerys's brother prince
rhaegar targaryen will be obsessed with
a century and a half later he was a
bookish kid and something he read in the
scrolls convinced him that he needed to
become a warrior for a time he thought
he was the prince that was promised and
then began to think it was his son all
of this led to his running off with
lyanna stark which set things in motion
for robert's rebellion and his dying in
single combat with robert baratheon at
the trident and of course the birth of
jon snow who ned passed off as his
bastard how this plays into things here
is unchartered territory since this
isn't mentioned in the source material
but this is a bit of information that
george rr martin gave to the showrunners
to include the saris believes it's a
burden to know about aegon's dream and
did what his tradition and what he
believes is his duty passing it on to
his heir renera there's really no reason
for him to tell anyone else which would
make things interesting if her claim
were to come into question and i think
you got the idea by his second birthday
that there are several people in the
king's orbit that would like to see that
happen in favor of the new baby aegon
rhaegar came across this somewhere and
knowing the story i can think of a few
different reasons rhaenyra might write
this down for him to discover later but
we'll have to wait and see where they're
going with it these shots in the trailer
seem to show that it adds some weight to
the bond that becerras and his daughter
have a sense of shared duty that's in
contrast to the problems we've seen them
have in their relationship at one point
in the voice over they mentioned that
aegon is now three so it appears that
we'll jump ahead another year it's hard
to say if this will happen in between
episodes or if time will just pass
because it looks like roniro will be
spending some time meeting potential
suitors based on this shot of her
sitting next to lord baratheon and what
i imagine is storm's end that might
involve some traveling which takes time
and while it might not be practical for
them to build sets to do too many of
these pretty much every house that had a
male child old enough to be considered
would be trying to get them in front of
renera
it sounds as though the process has gone
on for a while and that she hasn't found
anyone she's interested in we hear
viserys say that her courtship is at an
end she fires back so i can be a remedy
for your political headaches to which he
responds that she is his political
headaches we did hear him tell otto that
he wanted her to be happy and then later
tell her that she could choose but it
looks like he's reached the end of his
patience with that process one thing
that he has over her now is that he can
make aegon his heir so he can force her
to make a decision if she doesn't want
to lose her position so it looks like
there will be some continued tension
between these two and then to complicate
things probably the first thing that
jumps out in this trailer is damon's
return to king's landing we see him
wearing a crown with his hair cut short
and hear him tell his brother that he's
been named the king of the narrow sea
which in case you're wondering isn't a
position that existed before him this is
all tied to his victory in the
stepstones and i mentioned in my episode
3 video that his charge would probably
become the stuff of legend remember at
the end of episode 1 they had words
before becerra sent him away it's been
years now and it's been established that
they do care about each other but
considering what happened at dragonstone
and in the stepstones it didn't seem
like beceres would be eager to welcome
him back there's a shot where you see
him approach the throne and one of the
king's guards stops him with the point
of his blade there's not much more i can
say about this that wouldn't be spoilers
other than it would make sense for
beceres to be somewhat hostile at first
if he didn't return at the king's
request plus he ordered him to return to
his wife but it doesn't appear that he's
been spending much time at runestone if
he's been busy being the king of the
narrow sea the next interesting shot is
another one that was tied to that weeks
ahead trailer it's a shot of belarian
skull and you can see someone walking
past it in the other trailer you get a
better look and it appears to be renera
in disguise sneaking out of the castle a
little while later there is a sequence
of shots with damon wearing a hood and
rhaenyra running in these clothes
somewhere in the city at night we know
that damon liked to spend his time on
the street of silk the brothel district
where we saw him in those scenes with
mazaria there are a couple of shots of
him wearing that robe that happen in
dark places and one where we see a
woman's hand sort of being seductively
covered by a man's that is probably
demons based on the ring this is where
it all gets interesting for book readers
because i have a general idea of what's
happening here and what might lead to
this other shot of viserys going off on
him in the weeks ahead trailer but don't
know exactly to what degree damon's
enraged his brother there are a few
different accounts with some of them
being much worse and we'll have to see
what the show decided was the real story
in most cases you have to imagine that
the truth lies somewhere in between the
most vanilla description and the
craziest one but either way you hear
otto tell the king that he has
discomforting news you hear rhaenyra
tell someone that this is a bile
accusation becerras ask his hand who is
responsible for the gossip because he
wants to take their eyes and alison says
that it's not in manira's nature to be
deceitful but she cannot say the same
for damon so it looks like this episode
will be saucy and we'll get some brand
new stuff with the prophecy plus some
clarification on what really happened
compared to the unreliable history and
the return of damon it should make for a
good episode i'm looking forward to it
and i think that is a good place to
leave things let me know in the comments
what you think we can get into book
spoilers if you want but please mark
those accordingly so they won't spoil
anyone else let me know what you're
looking forward to based on this trailer
and episode 4 and the rest of the season
in general please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon